(indistinct conversation)
- Guys, the iPhone X is behind me,
it's officially announced the iPhone 10
a.k.a iPhone X.
It was the one more thing.
The one more thing that
we were all waiting for.
I'm gonna give you guys a closer look.
This is live, so whatever
happens, happens.
I'm not sure what's gonna happen.
But, let's take a look at it.
Here it is.
I comes in the black version,
and the white version.
Nobody wants to see the
back of it apparently,
so we need to get around
and show you guys the front.
One of the things that
I'm most excited about is,
well, they did a demo of the AR gaming
which was actually really really cool.
Way cooler than I thought.
And Iphone X will be
available November 3rd.
Pre-orders will start on the 27th,
which is a little bit later
than when the iPhone 8 came around.
I'm trying to get in here guys,
I'm trying to get for ya.
Here it is.
There is the front.
Look at it guys.
(indistinct conversation)
They did a really cool
demo of how the facial,
it's called the Face ID works.
It's really really quick.
Well that's it for now.
I will be posting a video later today
but I just wanted to give
you guys a quick live look.
Maybe I can take you guys to the iPhone 8.
Let me see, I might as well.
I'm gonna sneak over there.
I'm gonna go see what I can show you.
Hi I'm live!
- Hi.
- Hello, hello.
Okay let's see if I
can see something else,
I'll show you.
I might as well just give you the whole
lay of the land here.
This is the new Apple Watch series 3.
It comes in a really nice ceramic black.
I'm probably still gonna get the white one
but we can still take a look.
Awe they look so good.
Okay, that's it for now.
I need to film some stuff.
I will see you guys later.
Bye.